pas cool les gars vous avez fait de
l'alcool alors que nous on crève la
dalle quoi qu'est ce que tu veux dire
c'est pas cool quoi c'est pas cool
l'alcool c'est pas cool oui c'est pas
cool ça que tu dis ben l'alcool c'est
pas cool oui c'est pas cool
quoi c'est pas con le véridique c'est
tout l'alcool c'est pas cool la falla
sait pas quand pourquoi y aller on coule
d'alcool
ouais ça devrait s'appeler là le cool
bienvenue cette île de chewbacca loi
vous allez devoir survivre pendant 38
jours sans rien vous êtes sûr que c'est
là parce que ya pas de village thermal
kerry ont battu construire nous mêmes
tout construire avec quoi anne nos mains
peut-être
ils devront dépasser la fin aux crabes
lada il n'y a pas de déjeuner ni de
dîners roi la fatigue va bien dormi
plutôt bien oui les trahisons évidemment
je vais travailler qu'on va te contredis
ce soir
mais non en gros t'es une merde on
l'attendait
waouh
oh [ __ ] c'est aux sauvegardes seul de
ses 14 aventuriers succèdera à lionel
pierres emporté 450 euros une somme
folle rien ne l'empêchera de gagner 450
euros la guerre fait que commencer j'ai
envie de faire partie de cette aventure
humaine tétouan mât ne ménageant aucun
secret pour moi c'est la bonne humeur
sur alarme qui me font à gagner
tout est lente
[Musique]
voulons tête vomir c'est le seul moyen
de faire du poids rapidement
c'est ça ce qu'on appelle le multivers